I've been getting a little bit of client
work done, but I've gotten bored. So,
um, I figured I'd come back and do a
short stream this morning before gym.
And, um, I came up with something kind
of cool last night.
I wanted to show this off.
So uh we have this issue right where we
needed an RMS norm to be stable
and
it was really annoying because RMS norm
is very slow for small models.
Check this out. I did
I added um a bit to the linear layer to
get a third chunk.
So then I take this additional
projection
and sigmo sigmoid and multiplicative
gate here on the output.
19 seconds. Not bad, right? It's
actually one of the lowest scores I've
seen. And it's pretty much uh you know,
it's it's pretty much always more
consistent than RMS norm as well. So,
this was pretty interesting to me,
right? Um,
now there are a few things I want to do
here because uh like with this in mind,
I kind of realized that there's a whole
class of new architecture changes I can
explore with this bowl. There's like a
whole class of new architectures I can
explore based on this, right? Cuz like
the thing I realized, let me explain to
you why this was nonobvious to me.
Okay, like this is a standard LSTM.
Where's thing? Yeah, here. So, this is
like your LSTM gate system. Uh, this is
actually a really bad diagram. Where's a
better one?
This is better. Yeah. So, this is like
an LSTM. Uh, the thing is Mr.
Yeah, Mr. Right here is it's like very
few gates. So it's not very expressive
and it's actually it's missing a couple
core things. Uh but you need this in
order to be able to do the linear time
recurrence for parallel training. But
the thing that I didn't realize is that
you can still do additional gates on the
input or on the output. You just can't
do gates on the state. So that actually
leaves us quite a bit of room for
architecture design. And this is
actually I got the idea from this paper
here. This is like just some random
paper. They did it really badly. I don't
know why they they chose a really dumb
activation for this thing. Um, but yeah,
like it now it seems like I have it
working.
Oh, yeah. There's a better diagram as
well.
All right. So, um, we're pretty close
now then to being able to put together a
prototype of this for release. Uh, we're
still a bit of perf shy and I'm going to
do a short stream right now. So, what I
wanted to do is I just wanted to play a
little bit with
our kernels
and see um,
basically just see if I can find any uh,
anywhere that we can improve
substantially.
So I know that the fuse scan off is
quite slow.
Hey Jason,
same experiment some more. Open a new
issue. Is it the um I guess I can merge
the down sample thing. I thought we'd
fix that though.
Like I thought that we had fixed that
already.
This isn't you though. This isn't your
PR, right?
This was um that did this environment.
Let me see.
Frictionless purple.
Did you try retraining it to see if it
made a difference? If it fixes
something, we like I'm fine fixing it. I
want to make sure this doesn't actually
like break the environment or something.
Equations are
I'd also want to make sure that we match
the actual implementation that people
use
cuz like
how do they actually implement it? Does
the implementation follow this or does
it follow this?
Struggling to recreate a full game
environment. Elatro. Well, that's a big
game. Learned a lot in the process.
Yeah, that's a big game to start with,
right?
I wouldn't recommend somebody start with
that unless they're pretty like a pretty
darn experienced low-level dev.
That would be a Let me think.
Well, I guess it depends how much if
you're doing the shop and everything or
if you're just doing um
the core mechanic.
No, you could do the court mechanic
decently quickly. I would say it'd be
medium complexity.
Okay. Yeah. I don't know why this is
this way.
15. Oh yeah. If you're going to try if
you're actually going to try to do that
then yes.
Same as Anderson and gem
implementations.
Didn't test. I definitely want to test
this then because we don't want to break
the thing. I wonder if this makes it
easier or harder.
I think it's just going to be easy
either way. We'll see though.
I mean, I can definitely see at least
this one is off.
Wait, where's this? Hang on. Denominator
should be
marginal difference.
Yeah. I mean, we'd like to have it
matched for sure. I'm trying to see. I'm
just trying to figure out how the hell
this was messed up. Um, like this is not
that hard of an end to implement.
Oh, this is total mass and then this is
supposed to be pole mass.
That looks correct. Yeah. Okay.
Huh.
There.
He wrote that one.
I send it to him.
Okay. I send that to him to go test
and um I look at this. So
right, what I was going to do is I was
going to look at this kernel and just
see like how much these exponents and
stuff are costing us.
Oh, your advisor is Anderson. That's
funny.
Carpole is like nowadays it's super
simple. I mean because Jason we don't
restrict oursel at all in samples. So
like
carpull's just solved instantly
basically because if we just throw our
normal batch sizes that we use for
harder ends at it, right? Like
it's funny because we'll use like I
don't know a few million samples to
solve carpole and it'll be faster than
uh other people's implementation where
they're using a few thousand or
whatever.
I'm trying to think then why why would
this implementation be slow? We have
branching here.
Well, we also we don't need to time the
whole thing. We have our fernal bench.
actually double and triple like uh
pendulum stuff would be pretty good
environment
any training by state dynamics.
Yeah, you can try for sure. Um, learning
state dynamics with Q-learning.
Puffer people in different environments.
Learning state dynamics
optimizing fun things. Yeah, I the thing
is um puffer has a quite different
direction in the sense that we have
we're very optimized for high throughput
and high hardware utilization, right? So
like the idea here
um we now can train this is breakout
that I have as a test that I'm playing
with and we can train this at 7 million
steps per second on one GPU. Uh for
comparison if you grab the classic Atari
implementations with uh like an LSTM and
stuff you'll literally get stuff under a
thousand steps per second. Some of the
implementations maybe a few thousand.
So, we were literally training thousands
of times faster than um the normal stuff
that people use.
It's a pretty different regime. The cool
thing though about this is like when we
do things this way, uh RL actually
becomes pretty stable and consistent.
It's like a quite different field.
Learn next date.
Yeah, I I really have not had a lot of
luck with next date prediction, man.
That's the world modeling type stuff if
you think about it. I have not had um I
really have not had luck with anything
that tries to predict full next state.
There is some like state based
exploration stuff I'm looking into at
the moment, but I like I'm very
intentionally trying to avoid predicting
next state or next state embedding
Oh yeah. So this this definitely does
not work with um
with harder tasks because you need an
agent to get you data that gives like
you don't get state coverage with a
random policy, right?
So you can't pre-train because you need
the agent to collect dynamics data.
This is why a lot of like these older
papers like did not end up working on um
like harder tasks.
There are a lot of assumptions that are
baked in that are true of MS like
heartpole that are not true of harder
MS.
It's actually one of the the big
problems with the original Q-learning
form.
Any reason you want to avoid it? I did a
whole bunch. So, I've done a whole bunch
of work on attempting to replicate stuff
from uh various world modeling lines of
work and it's very slow and it's very
fiddly. It does not seem particularly
promising to me. The results don't match
up with um what's on paper.
68. So that would be substantial
overhead, right? Because you have four
of these.
Actually log co both of these backwards
passes would be
bottleneck, right?
can ignore the log [ __ ] but we don't use
that one.
Okay, our mining grew gate is like much
better, right?
Oh, yeah. We're mostly going to be
timing dispatch though because this is
not grapping.
Well, we can still do something with
this.
a red swag.
New world model trust elementary. The
thing is like even if the best known
papers in that space just do not work.
I spent a good um
couple weeks on this more even over the
summer.
All right, let's try a couple things
here. So this log cos and values
backwards and this is scan backwards
Okay.
Ah,
underscore.
Let me see if this does anything real
quick.
Um
Do I have to recompile? I do have to
recompile this, right?
Huh. Okay. So, apparently there is some
instability here.
Let me just see if this does anything
first.
Hello, Electro.
No, wait. 168.
Yeah. So, this same speed.
So, this did not do anything.
That's not where we're getting held up.
Um,
I'm trying to think if we can get uh Oh,
actually, doesn't this have
Isn't there um the other What's the
kernel profile? Nvidia,
is it KUA? What? No. What's the other
one? That's not NISS. NCU.
right. Do we have any kernel folks in
the chat? Um,
I'm trying to figure out how we actually
really start to optimize these kernels.
Uh this is at the moment we're playing
with a couple of the kernels that are
left in puffer
um that still have like substantial
overhead on
Wonder if I can just like comment. I
have to disable the correctness checks.
Let's see if I can just like
just do like some stuff like this, you
know.
Well, I wouldn't want to do it on the
for actually. The Ford is fast.
Yeah, the forward's super fast.
Actually,
it's the backwards.
didn't have stream yesterday. No, I was
doing some client work. I'm just doing a
short stream today as well. Um, I've
been alternating between like full days
of work and then days where I do a few
hours of work, long gym session, few
hours of work. Tomorrow I'm going to do
the um I think tomorrow if I can get it
set up, I'm going to do the Opus stream.
I'll announce it for sure later.
>> I highly doubt that. I'm surprised, but
we shall see.
Yep. So obviously this is numerically
bad
Huh? I commented all of this and this is
only um
that seems weird. Wait,
is this somehow like the launch?
Right. Oops.
R H.
I wonder if I'm just screwing up the uh
the launch or something on these
difficult to program CUDA. I have to do
this for my library as well. I mean, you
see what it is. CUDA itself is just see
that runs on your GPU. Like the thing
that's annoying at the moment is um
well, not even at the moment. The thing
that was annoying when I did this is uh
these are very numerically sensitive
operations with uh very fiddly
gradients.
So if you're using CUDA for something
that is not very numerically sensitive
operations with very fiddly gradients
that you need to manually compute, then
no, you're just writing C.
Okay, so it is actually the OP like this
does get to a bill.
I am kind of surprised this is actually
only a billion though, right? Cuz
this is not doing anything
cuz the forward speed. Oh, wait. No, the
sport speed is actually slow.
Launch log.
Let me see what this is.
block size for
Yeah.
I forget actually if you modify just
these CUDA kernels, do you need to
recompile?
I think you do.
Well, we're not doing a direct kernel
test.
I have an environment in mine 24 for
this for the Opus stream.
Going to build new environment. Well,
we're going to attempt to build new
environment. I think that we're not
going to get anything usable, but we
will see.
We do have to recompile
Wait, did I see this correctly?
Hang on.
Really? I think I should have a
benchmark that doesn't depend on
Yeah, we need more benchmark marks. I
think for this there needs to be a pure
cuda benchmark.
Okay, look. This is what I was worried
about. See
backward FPS.
And this is not this isn't doing
anything, right? Like look, this kernel
is empty.
No comment means no comment.
All right. No comment mean no comment.
this one is actually parallel? No.
size of N.
Honestly, I might read through these.
These look cool.
At the moment, I'm kind of just like
pulling on threads.
Okay. But we see this, right? Like
pretty much no matter what I do, this
number does not improve.
And uh this kernel is doing nothing. So
that's a problem.
Unless I I might just be uh checking
kernel launch overhead. Hang on.
But it shouldn't be 5x slower if that's
the case.
Let me figure that out.
Okay, so we have B, T, and H, right?
This is a full test
batch T.
Uh, is this how we use this? Wait, log
coin values.
This is not the actual situation that
we're going to use this under. Right?
I think it's V times T, right?
No. Um
No, wait. This is used in backward. I'm
dumb. Logistent values. This is correct.
Oh, well then these should be super easy
to get fast, shouldn't they?
Wait, Mr. Oh, no. Mining gate is
actually This is getting tested wrong
here
cuz this is getting a huge huge bash.
Yeah, but like look, the Ford SPS is a
bill.
So presumably
is it these dumb allocations?
How do I test this?
Oops.
I'm going to do something silly
if I just do like this maybe.
Obviously, this messes everything up.
But like I think if I just have the uh
the shapes correct, then we just take
the allocations out of the test.
Use code. Yeah, we'll see. Liberty. I
highly doubt I highly doubt there's
anything there.
Like my current impression of this is
that you have very heavily advertised
models where like a bunch of the people
at Top Lab who are normally quite
respectable are pushing them as well.
Some of them probably genuinely believe
it. Um the models are really good at
lying to you and telling you you're
smart. And then also there's like this
promise of well what if it just wasn't
horribly difficult to develop things and
you could just do things quickly. You
have things like people tweeting stuff
like oh you can just be developing while
you're spending time with your family on
Christmas. And it's just [ __ ] It's
not true. Like
everybody wants an easy way out of doing
the hard work, but there still has
there's never been an easy way out of
doing the hard work and there still
isn't one.
I think it's just uh mostly a case of
people wanting to believe the models are
good.
Okay, so look, this actually did make a
difference. But why is this 4x lower
than the forward kernel?
Let me actually just look this up. I bet
there's a better benchmark we can run.
Uh yeah, I have torch checks in here,
which is not good.
Oh no, wait. This is modules. This is
fine.
No, this current stream thing is fine,
right?
Just as a quick test, I'll see if it'll
write the um a timing for this.
specific colonel
vultures to your
Is XAI most talented?
Um, no.
Do you know the way that all these
companies work?
Well, I guess I don't know how big they
are now.
I they do have the advantage probably
when they're very small, but like the
way that it works is all these slabs
like the ones that get big quickly, it's
because they start very small with a few
very good people and then when they get
bigger, they lose talent density because
there aren't that many good people.
I like the most impressive place I've
ever been was Open AI where there were
like a hundred people and most of the
people there were very good.
like actually very good.
And does this match actually? That's
pretty close.
Yeah, that's actually pretty close,
right?
Okay, I actually like this.
Yeah, that's solid.
So, what I want to do, right, is I'd
like to just have all of my kernels in
that kernel file standalone.
And I'd like to have a profile script
that is just using MCU.
And um
wait, is this actually just MCU? I
didn't run this with MCU.
Oh, it forgot.
Oh, this is simple timing. I see. And
then run with Insight compute.
Okay, this is still good though.
Counters. Okay, so there's perms. Cool.
I like this still
space.
Uh, no I no idea if that makes any
sense.
It is cold up there.
Let's see what this thing did. I think
it just did some really basic timing.
Yes, but this literally just wrote a
loop.
Cheeky thing.
No idea.
Um
There are other like I there are other
ways you lose heat, right?
I mean, if I think of it as thermal
radiation, like if I think of it as a
wave, then it makes sense. I really do
not have a good physics background at
all.
How many screens do I use? too. I have a
27 in um just standard monitor like 2
feet in front of me. Uh a little longer
just over arms length and then I have a
27in vertical mount that I use for this
stream radiation delucy. Yeah. So I
think it is still freaking cold. I
actually don't know how that compares to
active cooling. Um because I know data
centers now it's not just air, right?
They're also well some of them are using
are what are cooled right? I actually
don't know which chips are and which
chips aren't.
See I don't have to think about this
[ __ ] because with the stuff that I work
on we just make everything so bloody
fast. We can run it on one machine.
All right. Um, here's an actual bit of
work for you guys to help me with here.
So, we have these, you see, we have all
these kernels in here. Um, what I'm
thinking is like I have all these
kernels standalone. What I'm trying to
figure out here is I want to be able to
run a test right on these kernels, but
then also on the torch kernels.
So, I'm trying to think, do I need to
like write out all the shapes twice?
What do you mean? What's my opinion on
distributed computation?
I don't know. Seven out of 10. I like
the way it distributes things, but the
computing part is a little iffy,
right? Like what do you expect me to
say?
Well, yeah. Big models need more GPU,
right? Like,
do you mean decentralized, not
distributed or something?
A no, I don't know what that is.
part of problem. No,
I have no idea what that is.
Well, we did find one thing from this,
right?
What's the plan? I just short streamed
today, man. I um I was doing some client
work and got bored, so I figured I'd
just go look at some kernels real quick
on stream. And then I'm going to the gym
in a bit. And then tonight I'm going to
set up for the uh Opus stream, which is
tomorrow
most likely.
I got some client work I've been doing
as well.
I'm trying to just understand a couple
things at the moment.
Well, this we have graphs for this,
right?
I do actually wonder about doing VF16
for our activations.
Let me go check these contiguous calls
cuz I didn't check that before.
Can we just not have like this on my
timeline, please?
like
Okay. So
uh this needs to be contiguous
evidently.
What if I put it in
What if I put it in here?
Oh, well actually we're timing both
here, right?
Yeah. Yeah, we are timing both,
so that's why.
Okay. I didn't realize I was timing the
forward passing this as well.
was dumb. We still need to make a full
test benchmark, I think, for this thing,
but it's not worth tuning kernels until
then.
I got to get to the gym pretty soon
here. Um, so I think I'm going to call
the stream, but I want to like just go
through real quick the plan. So,
essentially what I think the place that
I think we're at at the moment, um, for
anyone who didn't see this, I came up
last night with
here. Let me rebuild this so I can show
you.
I came up with something that I think is
pretty good architecture wise and gets
us up to about 7 mil. Um, we can get
above 10 mil with different settings and
it seems pretty stable, but now we need
to run a bunch of tests. So, what I kind
of want to do is I want to focus on like
actually
actually polishing this thing up and
then writing a whole bunch of proper
tests rather than just sort of like
fiddling with stuff. I think we're kind
of done fiddling with stuff officially.
Like there are no more easy Perf wins,
but I think that we can get up to the 10
mil if I just like polish and start
writing formal tests and assume that
we're going to like we'll get the rest
of the PF basically out of stacking a
bunch of little things.
This is the new thing for reference.
This is now sub 20 seconds for a solve.
There you go. 19 seconds. It's a little
slower this time. Um, and this does not
have an RMS norm and it's stable.
So, I mean, it it's a little annoying
because I would rather be at 9 mil right
now, you know? Um, stuff's a little
slow, but I think we can still get it.
But like the thing is the the probably
the biggest improvements I'm going to
make are going to be like things with
the kernels and whatnot. And that's just
not going to happen by me sitting here
and fiddling with stuff. So I think that
the most productive thing to do is going
to be to just like lock it. Say, "Okay,
we need to clean everything up, make
sure everything is good and stable, and
uh ideally get it to the point where we
can run sweeps." So I can be in the
background running sweeps to check
things, right? So I can test one
architecture versus another and things
like that. Um and then at the same time
I can work on like kernel benchmarks
like proper tests and we can really
isolate the last bits of Perf that I
don't know where we're losing.
I think that that should be good enough
for the last 3 mil because I've seen
I've seen the number 9 mil before
with like pretty similar everything.
So, I think we can get it.
Hey, Santiel. I'm just about done for
today. Honestly, this was just like a
quick hour stream in the morning. Uh,
I'm going to the gym for a few hours and
then I'm probably going to in the
evening I might stream. I got to set up
for the Opus stuff tomorrow. Uh, that
stream might I'll announce formally, but
I think it should be tomorrow. And
I still have some client stuff to get
done as well that I need to be cranking
on, but I think we've got a pretty like
we're actually in a pretty good spot
where I know what to do going forward uh
to get this release done. It's mostly
like actually polish everything up so we
can get the experiments running. Uh
proper kernel bench. Uh we have a couple
other benchmarks that we like that are
good and that should get us there.
All right. Well, thank you folks. I'm
gonna get ready for gym. Um,
my stuff's here. Open source at
puffer.ai. If you want to help me for
free, star of the puffer on GitHub. I
stream all my dev for the most part. So,
tomorrow I'll be live uh provided I get
the setup done tonight. I will be live
all day tomorrow with the promised opus
stream testing that model out to see if
it's any good. I doubt it will be, but I
came up with like a good standalone task
and people have been insisting on it.
We'll try it.